[Music]  the 20th season of Big Brother premieres  tonight - on CBS 16 new strangers will  compete for the half-a-million dollar  prize yeah but some of them however just  might want to rethink those strategies  it was a dumb jock I'm gonna try and  like play the dumb card my heads full of  sawdust I'm just gonna go in there and  play stupid I might play it down oh we  don't worry about him it's kind of a  nitwit so they think that I'm just their  summer cap let's party who's got the  bearer I want them to think that I'm  just like I don't know awkward just play  play dumb for a while I'm gonna walk in  and be like wait what wait what's it a  head of house oh okay and then oh and  then the wait veto I'm pretty good at  playing dumb so I think I was just gonna  do that the hold on hopefully they don't  figure it out that I actually know  what's going on  [Music]  [Applause]